[Musique]
où
je suis venu ici parce que j'avais un
concept
qui traitait pas en algérie je n'eus là
pour des recherches bibliographiques à
marie dauphine
je suis maître de conférences
[Musique]
je suis son fils elle est entre de
bonnes mains c'était quand même s'y
colle au gicm ans elle est allée au bord
de la rupture
moi personnellement je suis étudiante
ici mais j'ai ma mère qui est bloqué
chez moi depuis quatre mois on est dans
dix mètres carrés c'est mon studio
allemand né dans dix mètres carrés
depuis quatre mois c'est pas possible
elle a laissé mon père a laissé notre
famille et laisse son travail qui n'est
pas du nom chez moi je vais aller plus
pour rester ici mon pays c'est là j'ai
réussi le fait rentrer chez moi mes
enfants et mon mari je les laissais
malades
[Musique]
on peut passer à la télé et dire que ça
se passe mal il ya beaucoup de familles
qui pensent qu'on est on est
correctement logés pour les trois-quarts
non c'est pas bref il y en a qui passent
leurs journées dans les bus et le soir
et rentre juste pour dormir
histoire de pas être un fardeau c'est
pour les personnes qui les qui les
hébergent
[Musique]
si la première fois à ma vie je suis
quarante deux ans chaque jour j'ai pu et
sa jauge j'ai apprécié les mises à fond
mise au fond mon travail en blade et les
stopper je marche à 4 heures du matin
j'écris j'ai l'angoissé le stress
quand même
pourquoi le gouvernement ne fait pas la
réciprocité pour envoyer des avions
d'air algérie et rapatrier les citoyens
qui sont bloqués la zone est un
lamentable ici jusqu'à quand ça va durer
on n'en peut plus
[Musique]